une onde de choc capter de l'espace le
volcan sous-marin hung aux tonga à bail
est entré en éruption dans le sud du
pacifique
la force des explosions entendues à des
milliers de kilomètres à la ronde a
causé la panique des vagues de plus d'un
mètre d'eau déferler sur les îles tonga
située à 65 km au nord du volcan sont
sous marines quand les peu profondes le
contact trop magna est très explosif on
croit que l'eau va être à nouveau quand
celle inverse l'eau se vaporise et
augmente l'explosivité de l'ensemble est
donc on avait des options très violente
les résidents ont fui tant bien que mal
vers les hauteurs de l'archipel qui
compte un peu plus de cent mille
habitants les torrents ont dévasté cette
église pris de court certains ont
affronté la vague au son de la musique
des îles
les cendres projetées dans les airs sont
retombés sous la forme d'une pluie noire
et de petites roches volcaniques le
nuage
volcanique
un bloc le soleil sont importants dans
ce tome on fait comme la nuit là-bas
pendant la shoah
des vagues importantes ont également
déferlé sur les îles fidji à plus de 800
kilomètres les samoa américaines ont
lancé la leyre
ces débats qui vont très vite vont à 7
cm à l'heure et elles peuvent augmenter
de un peu d'altitude en arrivant près
des côtes
plus les vagues ont finalement frapper
les côtes californiennes causant des
débordements comme ici à santa cruz
les alertes au tsunami ont aussi forcé
les évacuations au chili les côtes de la
colombie-britannique plus éloignés de
l'éruption font aussi face à un avis de
tsunami le volcan n'en est pas à ses
premières frasques mais cette fois ci il
a expulsé sa colonne de fumée à une
vingtaine de kilomètres dans les airs et
son avenir demeure incertain ici jean
phlippe yules radio canada montréal